sobrevolando la amazonía las autoridades
brasileñas intensifican su combate
contra la minería ilegal en la tierra
indígena llanumami desmantelaron el
viernes un campamento ilegal de mineros
en búsqueda de oro
[Música]
hemos establecido las bases de control
para frenar el suministro logístico de
las actividades ilegales en los dos ríos
principales y ahora Estamos Comenzando
la siguiente fase de la operación que es
atacar estos frentes mineros
cuando llegaron las autoridades la
mayoría de los trabajadores ilegales se
fueron corriendo abandonando su material
pero este minero de 36 años no logró
escapar la minería nunca acabará la
minería es una fiebre es una adicción
vas una vez y nunca quieres irte yo gano
mil dólares por semana en qué lugar de
la ciudad se gana eso según los líderes
de anumami unos 20.000 mineros
clandestinos habrían invadido
violentamente su territorio cometiendo
abusos sexuales las mujeres y causando
enfermedades por la contaminación de los
ríos
tenemos mucha diarrea y vómitos aquí no
tenemos salud ni ayuda nada
la minería ilegal en la selva brasileña
aumentó considerablemente bajo el
mandato de Jair bolsonaro el año pasado
un centenar de niños ya no mami menores
de 5 años murieron por desnutrición en
enero Lula decretó la emergencia
sanitaria en la zona para que las
fuerzas armadas puedan expulsar a los
mineros que se resistan a salir pero el
proceso promete ser largo